- (laughing) I am so excited by it.
Now, it's time for the
straight shooter to deliver.
(audience cheers)
We have Stephen A. Smith
on the line right now.
What's up, Stephen? (laughs)
(audience cheering)
- Hi, Kelly. How are you?
- (laughing) Oh my god.
That's what your face looked like
when we were in the suite. (laughs)
So, by coincidence-
- It's unbelievable.
- I can't even...
Can you even believe, when
you walked in the suite?
I was like, "We're in
the same suite? What?"
They put us in the same suite-
- [Stephen] I know.
- at the Super Bowl, and...
I know, oh my god. So freaking funny.
So, you... Were you freaking out?
As that game clock was winding down?
Yeah, and I was looking
at you like, "Ohhh!"
- I was, I was.
I thought the Eagles had 'em.
I mean, they still went up
24 to 14 in the first half.
I was was like-
- [Kelly] I know.
- This is good.
I'm a have Kelly Clarkson
singin' a song to me.
(Kelly laughs and claps)
I mean, this is beautiful.
And the next thing I know, you
know, everything fell apart.
You know, I didn't expect that.
It kind of caught me by surprise.
But, it's all right.
I mean, you got the best of me.
I mean, it's embarrassing.
I mean, I'm a sports
analyst losing sports bet
to a premier singer and talk show host.
(Kelly clapping)
But you know, I mean, these
kind of things happen.
- Thanks, you're amazing.
- I just have to deal with it.
I have to take it.
- Oh, my god!
I gotta be honest with you,
no one I know saw that coming,
but I will tell you, my favorite part
of the entire Super Bowl, even topping...
'Cause I loved Rihanna and Stapleton,
Babyface, everybody, Sheryl Lee,
everybody did such a great job, that...
The players, everybody.
But my favorite part of the Super Bowl
was turning around and
looking at you, (laughs)
right before the Chiefs won. (laughing)
(audience laughs)
I mean, it was, it felt so good,
and I just couldn't
stop laughing about it.
I was like,
"I don't know how this is
happening, but I'm so happy."
And is there anything else,
though, you want to say
before you announce your
new favorite team? (laughs)
- I'm not announcing a new favorite team!
(Kelly laughing and clapping)
That is not the bet we had.
The Dallas Cowboys...
No, I'm not doing it, Kelly.
- I don't remember it this way.
- [Stephen] But I will say this.
- I will say this. I...
- [Kelly] Get it out!
- Hold on, hold on.
(Kelly clapping)
I...
I love the Cowboys!
- Oh my god!
(audience cheers)
- I said it, okay?
- You heard it here!
- I said it, all right?
(both laughing)
- Oh my god.
Oh my god, I love you so much.
Hey, you owned it, and you did it.
You followed through with the bet.
That's a man of your
word, I'm just saying.
Cowboys lover: Stephen
A. Smith, everybody!
(audience cheering)